Hey youtubers it's Charlie this week for my
bonus Arrow video I wanted to talk about my
top 10 characters from season 2. I'm excluding
Oliver and most of Team Arrow, just because
they would hog half the list and there were
a bunch of new characters that deserve to
be mentioned. I'm still catching up after
being out of town, so instead of doing separate
Flash video this week I'm just going to do
a quick update on some new info.
If you're finding me for the first time I
do Marvel and DC videos every week. Be sure
to subscribe to get everything. Feel free
to leave me suggestions for bonus topics about
any of the comic book tv shows or movies.
So before we do Arrow, the big Flash update
is that the producers confirmed John Wesley
Shipp was playing Barry Allen's father, Henry
Allen. He's going to be in several episodes.
In the comics his character dies in prison,
so either the show will just use him in a
lot of flashbacks or they'll change the comic
story so he can be alive in present day. Either
way it's confirmed.
Now, let's talk about the best Arrow characters,
starting with number 10 - Doctor Ivo
Such a huge villain from the comics, I got
really excited when I heard he was going to
be on the show. They opted to dial him way
back from his comic book persona and make
him more of a tragic villain at the end of
his rope. They did humanize him eventually
teasing his daughter and wife. But the biggest
easter egg was the Amazo Boat. Amazo for those
who don't know is a Justice League villain,
he's like DCs version of Ultron with a few
differences. Amazo can mimic anyone's powers.
So think of the future Sentinels from Days
of Future Past.
I was a little disappointed they didn't tease
the Amazo Android, but because Season 2 was
all about the mirakuru serum I understand
why they kept a lot of comic book stuff out.
Everyone also started wondering if he was
secretly Felicity's father. I think, given
what the producers have said and the way things
went down, that's not the case and Felicity's
dad will turn out to be someone even cooler.
Ivo on the other hand could totally have been
doing other types of research we just didn't
see. The way I think about comic book stuff
is like this. If you don't see it on the show
and none of the actors or producers ever talk
about it. There's still a chance it could
happen in a future season. So we could totally
see an android down the line. Until someone
says definitely not, it's still floating around
in an imaginary closet.
9 - Brother Blood
Kevin Alejandro really came into his own in
the second half of the season, they turned
the demonic aspects of the character from
the comics into metaphorical ones. Brother
Blood talked about wearing the mask as a way
to conquer his demons. On the show he ended
up becoming more of an analog for The Scarecrow
from The Dark Knight Trilogy. A scientist
with a formula.
Before we learned all the details about the
mirakuru I actually thought the League of
Assassin's was helping him just because of
the fear toxin in Batman Begins.
A lot of you guys asked me if he maybe secretly
survived being stabbed by Isabel and all I
can say is until the producers confirm he's
dead or we see a severed head. He can always
come back. Think of it as comic book logic.
8 - Malcolm Merlyn
I think the real crime on Arrow this year
was that John Barrowman didn't get more episodes.
And based on what's going on in Season 3 it
sounds like the writers agree. John Barrowman
was upgraded to cast regular for Season 3
meaning he's going to be in most of the episodes.
Like more than half of them which is 12 or
13.
Even though he only appeared a few times,
he's one of the most memorable actors playing
one of the biggest Green Arrow comic book
villains. He's essentially meant to be a foil
to Oliver. Like the darkest timeline version
of Oliver.
So when we start talking more about Oliver's
Journey in Season 3, we'll be able to figure
out some of what Merlyn is doing.
So far my biggest prediction is that Oliver
will be in rebuilding mode all season and
going back to basics. The focus on the first
couple of episodes will be the core team arrow.
Stephen Amell said Oliver and Laurel really
haven't addressed the big WTF secret identity
in the room yet. So that makes me think she's
not going to formally become a member of Team
Arrow till later in the season.
That means Merlyn is probably in rebuilding
mode too and Thea is just the first member
of his new team. Thematically I always like
it better when each character has an opposite.
Like Oliver and Malcolm. I think we can call
Thea Roy's new opposite. I'm sure he'll be
really happy to learn about that.
7 - Sin
How can you not love Roy and Sin during the
second half of the season. I was bummed she
didn't get more episodes too, and that she
was kept out of the loop on everything. She
didn't know anything about the mirakuru, Sara
never told her about the League of Assassins
and they never really addressed what her character
would be doing now that she was on her own
again.
It was only implied, but I think we'll see
more of her helping Roy with missions. I'd
really like to see her become a formal member
of Team Arrow by the end of Season 3. Plus
there's always the possibility of the Young
Justice spinoff. She could totally become
a part of that if it ever happens.
My favorite Sin moment was her and Roy trying
to fight crime on their own.
6 - Roy
My opinion on his character did a major 180
from the beginning of the season to the end.
That's just the magic of a character arc.
Laurel was on one too. But I like Roy's more.
Almost homeless dude gets injected with super
serum, goes crazy, survives and becomes member
of a mini Justice League. If only it were
that simple in real life.
My favorite Roy moments were training with
Oliver and when he was first trying to figure
out his powers after episode 10.
5 - Nyssa Al Ghul
One of the best new female characters on the
show. She was a master assassin that could
match Oliver in a fight, had the might of
Ra's Al Ghul at her back and in an interesting
twist, was one of the only LGBT characters
this season.
She was so awesome, there is no way the show
is not bringing her back.
My favorite Nyssa moment was actually a funny
one, it was at the end of the season when
she met Felicity and they had a little stand-off
moment. It almost looked like she was looking
at Felicity as sex object like she was sexually
attracted to her.
Tumblr, I'm going to task you with making
that reaction gif.
4 - The Canary
Caity Lotz had the hard task of stepping in
between Laurel and Oliver as a romantic foil,
but I got so excited when I saw her for the
first time. I took the first half of the season
to figure out where her character was headed
and yes I do wish she could have spent more
time teaming up with Oliver on missions. She
also had this really funny relationship with
Felicity that went from distrust to mutual
respect.
There was a brief moment when I thought she
we going to out Felicity Felicity, but spoiler
alert, that's impossible. There is only one
quirky tech genius on Team Arrow and she went
to MIT.
Sara can always come back for League of Assassins
or Laurel tie-ins, but for the most part I
think Caity Lotz is off the show. I'm really
happy that they left her character's exit
very open-ended. As in, she didn't die.
Passing that black canary jacket on to Laurel
is heavy foreshadowing.
3 - Amanda Waller
Hands down biggest new non-villain badass
on the show. I say non-villain, but she's
really a neutral figure in the DC Universe.
She serves the government ultimately, so sometimes
that takes her against superheroes. She tied
up a few big plot threads from season 1 and
started a few brand new ones in season 2 that
will largely inform the Hong Kong flashbacks
in Season 3.
She's like one of those Halo characters the
show will probably never kill just because
they're too interesting. Stephen Amell also
confirmed one of our biggest theories. Amanda
Waller was that woman with the Red Shoes behind
the whole Edward Fyers China plot. They were
trying to decimate China's economy.
One of the biggest things I'm looking forward
to in Season 3 is the Hong Kong flashbacks
telingl the story of Oliver and Waller's relationship.
2 - Barry Allen
Never has a new character so naturally become
a member of Team Arrow. Just talking about
the character first, Barry was the perfect
call to action for Oliver in the first half
of the Season. He's the one that gave him
that Green Arrow mask. Like he helped Oliver
make a giant leap forward in his hero's journey.
Obviously there's all the spinoff stuff going
on too. Based on the pilot episode, the CW
is saying that The Flash will be one of the
best new shows they've had in the last 10
years. There's a lot of reasons for that,
but having a very fun and positive lead character
like Barry Allen makes it a lot easier to
make a show people can get excited about.
Grant Gustin did an amazing job, before his
cameo on Arrow I only knew him from Glee.
And on that show he was something of a villain.
I don't see a lot of villain inside Barry
Allen, but I'm interested to see how he adds
some complexity to the character.
I think of him as being tortured, but if we're
comparing grumpy superheroes. Oliver would
win hands down. Barry is this hyper active
superhero fanboy. And look at how brightly
lit all of the scenes in the trailer are.
This isn't going to be noir like Arrow or
Gotham.
1 - Deathstroke
Manu Bennett is an amazing actor and he had
two full years to develop his Slade Wilson
character. The Deathstroke persona didn't
really develop until season 2. And even then,
it really didn't manifest until halfway through
the season.
He's going to go down in Arrow history as
one of the all time best villains, which creates
some issues for season 3. How do you top Slade?
He was like Macbeth on steroids.
I'm really hoping that the show uses him as
like a Hannibal Lecter character next season.
Like Oliver goes to him for help with whoever
ends up being the new villain. I actually
asked you guys to submit your fan art of Slade
as Hannibal so High Fives to Sumit Shetty.
Very cool.
I'll probably do more fanart submission videos
for other stuff in the future for anyone who's
interested.
So I realize I had to leave ton of awesome
characters off this list, but let me know
who your favorite was in Season 2 and what
your favorite scene of theirs was.
I'm still catching up after being out of town
for 4 days, but tomorrow I'm doing my regular
Arrow/Flash Q&A and a Maleficent Review if
I can see it early enough. Be sure to subscribe
to get everything. Otherwise that second thursday
video will be Marvel or Star Wars that I missed
yesterday. I'm definitely doing a Maleficent
Review before Saturday though.
Right now click here to learn more about Arrow
Season 3 and the Flash and click here for
my X-Men Days of Future Past Review.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!